as predicted by anyone who has been
following the way Donald Trump behaves
for the last many years
upon the verdict of 17 guilty counts for
Donald Trump's organization in this
massive fraud case out of the Manhattan
District Attorney's Office Donald Trump
explodes first and foremost the message
posted to Twitter by Donald Trump's
Soviet style PR person Liz Harrington
and Trump in all caps calling it The
Manhattan Witch Hunt putting out the
following statement and I it's always
physically demanding to read these
things quote disappointed with the
verdict in Manhattan but will appeal
after looking at millions of pages of
documents over many years much to the
detriment of record-setting murder and
other forms of violent crime that are
taking place in New York City
those are unrelated things the
government capital G was able to get an
employee to quote plea why is plea in
quotes I don't know that's quite
literally what happened in order for a
very reduced sentence this case was
about Alan weisselberg committing tax
fraud on his personal tax returns Etc
with he and every witness repeatedly
testifying that President Trump and the
Trump family with a capital f knew
nothing about his actions which he
admits were done solely for his own
benefit and with no benefit to the two
companies why would Capital C
corporations which knew nothing about
weisselberg's personal tax returns be
prosecuted for that person's conduct
there was Reliance by us on a then
highly respected and expensive
accounting firm and Law Firm to do this
work the accounting firm also did his
personal returns which we are not even
allowed to legally View
this case is unprecedented and involved
no monetary gain to these two Capital C
corporations it is the continuing
continuation of the capital greatest
political Witch Hunt in the capital H
history of our Capital C country New
York City is a hard place to be quote
Trump as businesses and people flee our
once capital G great Capital C City uh
none of that making a lot of sense and
the fear of course in Trump is that all
of this stuff is getting closer and
closer Trump not implicated directly
here in a legal sense but of course
Trump knows everything that goes on in
his businesses and 17 guilty verdicts
again try against Trump is
understandably and expectedly triggering
to the failed former president and this
was not the only bad news for Donald
Trump yesterday because we learned that
the Trump Riot committee will indeed be
making criminal referrals
when you're working during the day when
you're on the go and you're in the mood
for something sweet don't reach for the
candy bar go for something that's just
as good but without the sugar and carbs
our sponsor monk pack makes delicious
keto granola bars and nut and Seed bars
they're tasty crunchy gooey sweet and
salty I love them but each bar has only
one gram of sugar two to three net carbs
and about 150 calories perfect if you're
doing keto or low carb or low sugar you
can have a treat that feels indulgent
and satisfying without the guilt monk
pack comes in flavors like sea salt dark
chocolate caramel sea salt they just
launched two new flavors I love peanut
butter cocoa chip and dark chocolate
cocoa my favorite thing is the texture
I've tried a lot of these nut bars
granola bars monk pack is superior if
you don't agree you get your money back
and it is the perfect holiday gift go to
monkpak.com and get 20 off your first
order with the code Pacman the link is
down below